my hair back right this is the star but
what about the band then you know what
we tight as if long Sturgess stands up
and screams just a counter the vandana
this stanza becomes 6-foot or just
screams into the mic
okay he's putting the headphones on
early looks like he's always there mine
he's gotta take it off the baton you
better hurry up bro he's running out of
time
oh wait we did the screen keep it
straight boy hey hold on guys he's gonna
hold the time gonna hold the time he's
got a secret knife
oh he did wasn't it please the first one
but still I give it an 8.5 out of 10
that's pretty still well done
dudes been really fun to Sun around
perfect the back Tod bar got dad
all we tried to to HR down the Easter
there that's better early read from
monster yeah that's not an easy one
either right like you really call I got
that and ask for data Karen back what is
this new label here we could hold on to
it for the good tag and get him out of
the corner instead of chopping the
Pacino sneaking five she was swinging on
the ground yeah Berman attack for the
side switch
[Music]
late rolling crush for the knockdown
try to cover the uptick right there the
party this times advantage to exceed the
bar cancel yeah and you try to turn to
punish it on the other side hoping that
it was gonna whip and then you get a
punishment and if they just a little
t-bar smash not down here in the corner
back there cover the up check double
overhead block let's get the raw back
out now if it's icky actually calm off
that yeah
lots of pressure superdad slew the ki
blasts well the monster already - so
keep it in the air so he just goes with
a direction change level three objects
yeah the animal three
[Music]
we'll take the overhead there we're good
blocking below and they jump on the
dragon trucks blood spirit that these
defenses read they were committed to
commands off the combo yeah drop to war
I'm not sure yeah that's we're are this
is all about to be back nice and to gum
up the avocado instead of Smashing you
choose to vanish yeah I would have liked
city airs master said
right so he could have thought of Anita
happy and sparks out
a column for the projectile holds the
banner to get the buffer follow up
[Music]
get it all back here yeah dragon run
back to the corner and the sandals that
look like a fake right yeah look like
Samantha row is gonna be the option to
make you wiggle they cancel it to the be
more possibilities the ground
yeah burn through some of this life give
it to the sparking be peace available
though when I look like that's we goes
looking forward staggered to push the
first part but catches of the second top
[Music]
so long stare down a sparking down
character early try to drag around body
was gonna land on the beam and then have
blocks fun to set that up goes back to
the original side doesn't get clipped by
the emperor 21 but I'll follow up yeah I
like the tag
I think honey badgers doing jump out ll
above it he was like I don't really know
what to do a cell here pretty tall yeah
let's get that man out of here for a
second
we are staggering those lights each
teleport to the other side he has to
believe in that one right here I go jump
medium is just 2h directly but he does
get the two weights on the raw attack
that's a great look built the four bars
closely to the level one level three
solar kamehameha yeah the kill
two characters apiece
an advisor fours with 1/2 the heater
advantage here force of nothing
[Music]
oh the confirm
sighs man
who's expanding get aside from that
problem to come over to the corner level
3 afterwards
they're gonna kill but with Noah
sparking no guard cancel meter
availability real-time situational just
goes with the late over there to see if
spins mixer yeah it's just put by the
end of it so logo the black not an easy
spot to be in wow it doesn't even cancel
it anything out those tha just back that
finds get started never let go a little
bit work to go there's get one couple
these one more barn off yes there were
tons of - oh but you said uh-huh
and then that Gulf will jump out of the
corner from honey badger good music you
are cancel solo pays off that's on and
that's over the point of the confirm
that was great stuff the 2h little in
scrambling finish to that combo honey
badger yeah a little late great maybe a
javelin throw to arts though
why you looking at me it's the other me
real big uses of it as he was trying to
up back Roger is expecting that Wow we
tried the 2h that but those sir no sir
that was actually a good try yeah was to
a I feel like that's one of the moves
that got changed I can't remember who
has change to like be harder to to
ancient or afford to be easier that's a
good question there's a lot of moves in
this game that have been oh yeah they've
like change the property is my man
adjusted the bandana will see the guy
look the intros watch a second time I
feel like this is unprecedented yeah he
can't put the yeah he's pertaining to
put on again Wow alright I like it he's
like I am part off a couple you in real
life
laughter you have to support in effigy
this is gonna jump back yeah that's
really like the wall in this match a
Breitling and tell páginas this is gone
you do have to be careful about
approaching you see the whip on the head
first into the auto combo with a second
to bring it back to the ground you know
what's funny is that every time he does
this combo it always wish like that so
that means he's okay with it you know
Sophia bees are actually pretty good for
keeping characters together generally
especially when he's perfect attack to
aid and that miss Nesbit he called the D
doses preemptively as well as we have
nothing to expend was with again could
have been rolling cross vegeta vanish
beat the van and help and it's in a
backpack
Oh watch both videos so yeah it's cuz he
was expecting him to manage and very
smart
oh yeah just brought aegisub Machida to
spell the kill especially without
meeting the Asperger's going with a
rabid ki blast station that's perfect
right like that's what you want you want
to get the kill there without spending
any bar and if the soft I will take it
off to L class
to the ground one small snack Kosovo
fire one character at a time get the
command grab they're all level three
nothing too crazy some damage off now
well I thought you met the chocolates
for you oh yeah that's the signature
type of oh yeah each teleport back to
the front
yes the cool things about so since we're
Isis it moves you we have teleporting
moves like that you gain the back of a
funny little behind ya dragon run before
the assist connects show them the
cheetah got thinking about the real
threat from the blob want to get the
trash
one three
Big Bang bring itself for the kill
yeah this is looking like a clean game
frame for long stir especially the spark
install at the table you know if you get
a hit here that's 70% and of course the
true so player I should've done at that
time
yeah it'll work yeah some players on
that perfect axe
have to do all to be these two aces have
been really on point vanish and it
slides their back to the corner and the
first thing we saw Pro clunks the rise
is 2h attempt call out at me in there -
looking for us to begin - that was a
great confirm actually to see that that
it hit
he's gonna get a hilltop Walker as well
we'll be close yeah take as much as you
can get yeah I know
Rana DP a third intro this is on profits
actually ridiculous is he gonna put on
the bandana a third time No
ah he's betrayed his roots I mean you
didn't lose the last game to be fair
toss which now both of them look so
serious
and here at night even tried to reflect
after block with a jido fish is good
thing they get hit by the honey badger
that's what looks a little otter
reflects life so got to ever way to
close the distance all right then the
kid shows up the pudgy doesn't drag the
Russian before get out yeah that sister
extent here for the kill
that's awesome there's a bear early kill
on a very important you want about that
damage himself is what you get into the
shadow blade it's like a capture stay
right sanic that doesn't allow that
damage to come through anymore
man I can't believe that part's not dead
yeah I could never come back to buying
up especially the honey badger giving
the Hedgehog Vantage confirm this back
is an assist as well now so you have to
be careful you're on the ground up
against honey badly any staggers h Talib
roar no reflects the commander oh yeah
love that micro dash into the a dragon
rush wolf yeah that was an interesting
idea to be I think would like like make
up double side switch or something right
I was like the idea yeah so was gonna
push you back from one side and like the
original cycle got a block on we're
gonna decide you need it to block off
but did not come together how he wanted
it riot Javel it does finish the carrot
man he should meet dead he should be
extra thing
but he's alive and now he's out
not down at the corner here
that's now forcing the by the one
character again we're gonna spark up on
that character so I'll try and chase it
with the health manage but still can't
make a block there that's over try the
2h it there's the cancel
[Music]
the extensions now time to come back
down the jump back it kind of look like
he was respecting uppercut and then it
turned out looking dog to commit to my
facebook snap a gap all to H the heck
can't challenge once of to H play his
own game to get them out for that barn
on key all alone
all it did the backups two ages of the
people at the camp
he's been resting his whole time and to
kill without spending any extra bar
that's a good look
so two characters apiece perfect good
start around perfect attack built
another sparking for some really comes
out and gives it to you know what four
beats ultimate he's got a bar like I
said stable and hot bar not gonna steam
this Fenris comes up with the holy
symbol divine intervention eros below
look closely level that are gonna not
found what you got oh trying to hit a
button and you're dead honey badgers try
to sleep that's who L in there along
starting to go ended up getting the jump
out himself any badges took the headset
on
becoming one with the game snide nice
punished
right there at the back smash north down
to roll across here Oh - Peck - a trip
honey badger at all
it's the type of game you want to play
we can get it above
[Music]
I don't know yeah thought is gonna block
in car canceled we got one character a
piece now final game but sweet needs to
the qualify for top 32 on the winter
side stop a honey badger here before we
go contingent game loud level three now
you're out of the corner but you're warm
mix up a way for dime will one sturdy
piece it looked like you try to bait it
top 32 winners bandana comes off well by
Porter Rico proud that their boy made it
in the top 32 winners side was like that
was good yeah he's like man yeah I
messed it up but like such a wholesome
calm man from Luxor I even know what he
said but his body's just a success